francisco is with us in California hi
Francisco how are you I am great Dave an
honor to be on the phone with you thank
you you too sir how can I help
well I'm in a bit of a unique situation
I purchased a home it's a mobile home
and it's in an area where they actually
I don't know that they go up in value
but they at least keep up with with
inflation and no they don't land under
the mic but the mobile home doesn't well
okay land under it
the land is is for rent so it's in a
very very desirable city yeah rent the
rent area might be very desirable but
okay go ahead but in any how that the
mobile home I purchased was not
financeable so I took out unsecured debt
to purchase the home I had all about
fifty thousand across three different
loans we paid off about thirty thousand
so far and using the debt snowball just
aggressively getting at it one loan is
twenty two thousand to four thirteen
thousand and one for four thousand at
the rate we're paying off we're gonna be
done with it in two years good okay
my question is having the thousand
dollars from baby step one has been
great we haven't used a credit card and
I don't even know how long cut him up
best thing ever we ever did but at what
point I wonder should I stop to do baby
step three when you're through with aged
of - and now the
the home debt is all with all the debt
is home debt so we've been putting even
her tuition you put the mobile home debt
wherever you want to put it it's so
small what's your household income we
make seventy a year okay you're gonna be
debt-free in two years which is very
normal for someone working the debt
snowball right told me and then at that
point we would own the mobile home yeah
and I mean and so if you want to make
this baby step six you can make it baby
step six if you want to I don't care
because it's your you know it's your
home but it sounds like such small it's
such a small amount of debt and they're
in such small increments and you're
gonna be done in two years I wouldn't I
just call it baby step two and I just
treat it like it's credit card debt
because it is okay and go about it that
way yeah that'd be my plan and the other
thing I want you to consider is I don't
think this is a good long-term plan I
think 10 years from now you're not going
to be glad you've been living in a
mobile home for 10 years I don't care if
you're in a an area where the real
estate prices are masking the fact that
you are living in a mobile home
well the rent bear is so cheap and we
will be able to save up to buy a home
cash that's what I will beautify that's
what I said ten years but as a ten year
plan this is not a ten year plan if it's
a few more years and you're just going
to save and like crazy and pay cash for
a home at some point or put a
substantial down payment on a home a
traditional built home that's going to
go up in value in a traditional way
that's true but you know there are
mobile homes in Malibu that sell for a
million dollars but the mobile home
isn't what's selling for a million
dollars it's the fact that it's sitting
on dirt in Malibu the dirt is what's
selling for that and so the the the real
estate that's in and around this mobile
home is masking the fact that it is
deteriorating it's going down in value
and it's not a good long-term play now
instead of doing rent you want to call
it your short-term play that's okay it's
a little more expensive than
like but that that's a you know you can
justify it that way but don't don't get
this up in your head that this is a
smart 20 year game plan or 10 year game
plan it's not I wouldn't do it long long
term thanks for the call